the name chaos is usually synonymous
with nature
quiet coves the Greece of tourists
dreams but since last year many
associate the name with the refugee
crisis things are quiet right now
even in the camps but the images of
clashes between police and desperate
refugees are still fresh in the minds of
potential visitors and the islands
tourist industry is hurting we're seeing
far fewer tourists this year the number
of travelers from abroad has fallen
sharply it's down by almost 80 percent
compared to last year the hotels are
empty and you can hardly see any
European tourists on the streets
tourists from neighboring Turkey are
staving off a complete collapse but even
they are dwindling in number and often
stay for only a few days local
politicians know they have to polish up
the islands image but campaigns at
travel industry trade fairs and cheap
ferry tickets aren't enough the deputy
mayor of chaos seems at a loss
of course we can do more but you know
all this thing is something new for not
only for grace but the whole Europe I
think in the islands north a campaign is
underway called dreaming of chaos
Antigone mice trolley and other hotel
managers have asked friends and guests
to share their love of the island and
remove years of all those beautiful
sunny beaches purpose was a good picture
and nice short and good views of the
island because picture is a thousand
words bookings that my strategies
family-owned boutique hotel are also 50%
down on last year to make matters worse
the government has raised the country's
sales tax and imposed levies on alcohol
and other products it's a double whammy
for the young hotel manager we have the
taxes but we don't give it to the guests
but this is not good for us
the campaign will continue through the
summer hopefully luring European
tourists back to this holiday Haven